let's jump to this story my friends you
may be aware that since
the death of george floyd there's been
an autonomous zone in
minneapolis well the good news for
everybody is that
the activists have won black lives
matter is victorious chauvin was
convicted on all counts
we can all go home uh we have peace good
run everybody appreciate all the hard
work everyone did
and uh we'll see y'all oh wait hold on
i'm sorry they're refusing to leave
the autonomous zone activists calling
for minneapolis autonomous zone to
remain
until conclusion of remaining officers
trial well surely then they'll leave
right of course yeah probably no other
officers will get in any trouble
then there's kim potter oh yeah wait
another officer
now we have another one i will i will
mention this again just for the sake of
you know saying it
you got more second amendment rights in
the autonomous zone there than you do
in the outside outlying city i mean and
i mean like you hear these stories about
people like shooting randomly into
houses and garages
and i'm like well that's a little too
much
it's certainly more respect for gun
ownership i guess keeping the cops out
not
allowing it to be enforced so this is uh
you know
it's basically what they're doing i'm
afraid of this um this
the kent state shooting in 1970 i
brought up earlier like that was a
an unexpected tragedy and it was four
people
that got killed so like if we scale up
to the weapons of war that we have now
and if the national guard comes in with
helicopter gun ships and they're like
patrolling over top of these zones
bro they have those loose a hellfire
missile like which they're allowed to do
if they have extra judiciary
assassination go ahead and no one's
going to hell fire missile united states
like the united states under the
patriarch is allowed to do it to its own
citizens
they're not going to we say they're not
going to shoot kids at college either
ian you're right
they'll burn down a home full of you
know with children in it dude the
authoritarian
regime can do whatever it wants that's
the terrifying thing but but hold on a
minute you realize that back then they
had
cruise missiles and m16s and full auto
and helicopter
you know gunships and all stuff right
yeah but they didn't have the the tech
not like the tracking mechanisms that
they have now
so you're saying they also didn't have
the patriot act you're worried about
like a captain america winter soldier
scenario where they have gunships that
can just target people
and then kill all the undesirables no
i'm just afraid of the next generation
of the may 4th
uh shoot massacre of the college kids
they were out on a pro
peaceful protest throughout throwing
rocks at the national guard it doesn't
need to happen
because they already control the lines
of communication they already control
that
they know everything about you they just
they have control over everything but
like you were saying they're spying to
an insane degree the bundy ranch thing
where they were like turn around go home
arm people the atf went out there and
and decided we're not gonna blm
if some of that happened again what's to
say that they decide not to turn around
and go back this time
well the conclusion of the bundy thing i
suppose the conclusion or one of them
was that they killed a guy they killed
one of the friends of the bundys
my you know you want to know what i'm
worried about
you you made a good point a moment a
moment ago when i said the
the activists are saying they won't
leave the autonomous zone until the four
until the remaining officers trials
conclude and you said
yeah probably nothing wrong will go with
any other officers here's the best part
most of these cities are bringing in
cadets to handle this stuff
so if you if you got a 26 year veteran
of the force kim potter
and she is involved in this what do you
think someone who's a week out of the
academy
is going to do exactly that he's going
to be like it's my first right what do i
do
well remember two of those officers
involved in george floyd's death were
rookies right
right out of the academy we're gonna see
more of the same it's gonna get a whole
lot worse
yep and they're gonna need a
justification see look what these police
are doing you know i find the phoniest
though
i'm i just i you're you decide to be a
cop right now
like we're seeing mass retirements and
resignations and
you are joining the police department
dude i gotta be honest if it were me
i would rather live in a tent down by
the river
and fish for food in my bare feet like a
hobbit
then literally join a police department
because they're using cadets in
albuquerque albuquerque for instance
they're training cadets
in riot control like dude you're going
to get a guy who's like a few months out
of the academy
and they're going to be like well black
lives matter is rioting it's the summer
of
of peaceful protest and this dude's
going to make a mistake
inexperienced and then they're going to
be like see this proves it
even the new officers are bad it can't
be reformed
and then guess what dude i would not be
surprised if we see a bunch of rookies
end up in prison and they're going to be
putting a jumpsuit they're going to be
shackled and they're going to part walk
and the left is going to cheer for it
who would choose to do that for 20 20
28 an hour i guess 28 is better than 15
huh
yeah i mean it's horrible and crime is
going to grow go continue to go up
likely and as you mentioned you're going
to have rookies policing people more
often because the older
folk are stepping down the experienced
officers and that is going to be
a recipe for disaster
that's right that's all i have to say
about that that is this is exactly what
they're asking
it's what they want this is what they
want to happen and i'm not convinced
i don't think they have any regard for
the rule of law i think they just
want power as far as i'm convinced they
want authoritarianism
what do you do if you don't have cops
how does your society
second amendment okay so your society is
like a militia what i'm saying
you know i don't know out in the middle
of nowhere where everyone has the right
to keep and bear arms right and it's
like to a great degree or more respected
they don't have this kind of stuff going
on
it's true well to be fair people also
live further apart and you have less of
the french exactly
like you don't have the population down
look look in
in some of these areas it's it's it's
not like as dense as manhattan but it's
it's it's that's about neighbors look
when i lived in miami
we had a five-acre property we still had
neighbors fairly close
and we had problems with dogs we had to
go to the neighbors and be like yo your
dog we had a bunch of guns
well no no not down there but people
could have a bunch of guns it's florida
so florida's like
pretty good combos wild west but the
point i'm making is
you can be out in these in these places
and not deal with this stuff so
if there's no cops in these cities i
don't think it'll get bad because you
have a lot of crime elements that you
don't have
but maybe if people have the right to
keep and bear arms because the cops are
gone and can't no one can enforce that
you know i don't know maybe it'll be
better off or they continue to strip
people of their right to keep and bear
arms and then you just have these
rioters and
the mob going around bossing folks
around and they get their way across the
country you know what i got to stop i'm
gonna i'll give you a prediction that i
don't want to come true but i think is
obvious
the reason why it's gonna get really bad
first
new cadets being brought in to help deal
with riots that's going to lead to a lot
more
accidents and tragedies it's going to
result in an escalation of the riots and
an escalation of the resignations
regular citizens are going to say i'm
gonna protect myself
rioters rump about a suburb some dude
comes out of his house says get off my
property they start throwing bricks he
goes pop pop pop
yeah and then they make laws that strip
people their guns and then the drone
ships come in
like that's that's good i don't see that
i mean maybe in ten
five years after that if some guy comes
out sec 2a guys like pop pop pop
and because riders are in his
neighborhood and he gives them an excu
the government an excuse
as to why it's dangerous that for
citizens to have guns red flag laws are
needed but there's no police
well the point is if the police all
resign because they're being locked up
they'll use the feds
and then the the feds can't maintain
like you
you don't understand man there's not
enough federal law enforcement
to go to every city and have it and
maintain this it's not possible
the atf absolutely could not handle it
if the police weren't there to enforce
gun laws how many atf agents
yeah that's 100 percent true so there's
enough really that's it i think that's
what
i saw so the atf actually only has the
capability to
process five to ten thousand cases per
year right so
if every state or not even every state
just a handful of states decided they
weren't going to enforce federal gun
control laws which they're doing there's
nothing that the atf could do
and this is not unprecedented left-wing
states do this all the time that's what
a sanctuary city is they started
legalizing uh drugs while they were
still federally legal
right so when you get to the point where
cops all leave
and no one can enforce gun laws you're
gonna have the people like i mentioned
in chicago who are good honest
you know working families but they want
guns to protect themselves and they do
so illegally under the chicago's laws
which i don't think should
i think it's unconstitutional but if the
cops are all gone then
no one's gonna enforce that then when
the riots come out this guy's gonna be
like ain't coming near my kids
and they're gonna be like screw you uh
yeah then throw a rock and he's gonna go
get back get back
we've already seen in like portland a
few years ago a guy
drew his gun on some on some of the
black lives matter protesters who's
backing away
get away from me they arrested him well
you've already seen the mccloskeys yeah
i was just about to bring up the
mccloskeys
so what comes next the riots are
are if they if they continue to get
worse and the cops continue to resign
we have cadets but i think cadets open
up a huge possibility of risk because
these
these rookies are my opinion more likely
to go to prison
absolutely they're not going to have the
defense they're not going to watch the
course they're not going to have the
skill they're not going to have the
experience
they're going to trip and fall they're
going to panic and shoot somebody
and then the city is going to be like
they risen with you they won't know to
shoot their gun in the air that's chased
right
dude you got seniority
you've been a department for decades and
the city is like we will sacrifice you
at a moment's notice yeah you think
they're gonna do
anything for a rookie no they're gonna
be like bro you just got here we even
pay you yet we don't care
to the wolves with you son and then
they're gonna turn around and say like
see we are
we arrested and charged him with murder
and then this like 26 year old or 28
year old guy's gonna be like
i'm going to prison i guess that's right
it's illegal to be a cop because
they want you to arrest somebody but you
can't use force to arrest them because
if you do
they might get hurt or die and it's your
fault so you're better off just saying
sir would you would you like to be
arrested no okay please have a nice day
and carry on with your
your knifing spree speaking of knifing
spree to tie this back to what we're
talking about earlier i'm afraid
that if people aren't able to get guns
and there are fewer police we're going
to see a lot more stabbing like we've
had
100 different stories in the last two
days of kids
stabbing each other with knives so
people are going to take like boiling
oil or hot water
or knives and all this stuff way word i
acid maybe but no assets like
stuff that you have on hand in your
house to defend yourself
like i don't see this ever in any way
being a good ending
so um no the acid attacks do happen in
london
i'm looking at the numbers right now i
remember doing a video on this a while
ago when we were talking about gun
control everyone talks about how
peaceful
um london is or england is i mean in
2017 there were 472 acid
attacks that's insane that's just in
london now that number has been
decreasing 2018 only had 310 in 2019
only had 123. i wonder what those
numbers look like post lockdown
crime rates have gone up here i wouldn't
be surprised if they went up there as
well and people don't have firearms to
protect themselves well in these places
without firearms like for example
sweden you know what's happened when
they took the guns out uh the violent
crime didn't go away it got bigger and
they started to have grenade attacks
oh my goodness people don't stop wanting
to kill each other when you take their
guns away they'll just get more creative
when i went to sweden
uh it was only a few months before i'd
gotten there that someone threw a
grenade onto a balcony killing an
eight-year-old english tour uh it was
it was a the tourist family it was an
eight-year-old kid i think that was the
story and they threw the grenade on the
balcony blew up and uh kid died
there's a lot of grenade attacks in
sweden i think they have the highest
grenade attacks per capita outside
an established war zone yeah it's
comparable that's unbelievable yeah
i think there was a grenade attack when
i was there actually and this is why
people
people will try to use numbers about gun
deaths or mass shootings specifically to
make these comparisons between the
united states and other countries
first of all even if you did have a like
to like comparison like it would be
better to
look at states compared to other
countries the united states is massive
but also it's not really a fair
comparison you should just be looking at
massacres
or mass killings generally machetes and
because yeah because you haven't solved
the problem if just as many people per
capita or more are dying as a result of
massacres or having violent crimes
committed against them but they just
happen to not be
attacked with the use of a firearm yeah
it's not an improvement
it is 100 a human nature problem and a
culture problem
maybe uh maybe it's time to get out of
cities
yeah 100 and i think we all agree on
that get out of cities basically
it's so much better to be completely
honest you know one of the challenges
back in the day was like can you get
good internet
i got to be honest it is difficult but
uh it's getting better
you know i i think getting easier
especially with starlink elon musk
that project's gonna be it's gonna
change everything you know what i think
would totally own us
tim would just own us cons if all the
left wingers
us cons if if all the left wingers
stayed in the cities and didn't leave
and vote in other places to prove us
wrong about how great their policies are
going to work there that would really
i would cry they'd keep me up at night
they'd be like dang they sure showed us
and then all the dumb conservatives uh
all the dumb conservatives just come out
leave the cities yes start going to
places where your vote will actually
count
and matter every conservative needs to
go to texas
every single one including us yeah
here's the thing well texas
is that legislation which protects
people from social media
real estate prices are gonna well i
think i said this that uh you know
will chamberlain brought up texas is
working on a bill i think was introduced
that would
if you're a citizen a resident of texas
says if you're a resident
and you get banned from any social media
platform because of your political views
you can get an injunction and have your
account restored
so there's questions about how that will
work with the first amendment because
private companies have first member
rights as well
if they pass that though i think we
might instantly relocate
yeah you might be like everybody i'd go
to texas why am i not in texas
let's get i'm not turning blue uh but
that's exactly why i need to go there
and start voting stop it start voting
yeah yeah go to texas become a citizen
there yeah
start citizen i'll be a citizen of texas
change my residency
a resident of texas yeah resident sorry
well that's a constitutional carry
one yeah i i i didn't realize that in
texas you actually need like a handgun
license
and you have to do like a course yeah i
was surprised that is surprising to me
i thought the joke was that when you go
buy liquor they give you a gun yeah
exactly
it's the family guy yeah apparently not
sad apparently it's more like west
virginia and then you fire it into the
air like joy behar told you
joyce said too no one gets hurt just act
like yosemite sam you know he had the
right idea yeah
and then you spin the revolver then you
go and you spin the revolver and put it
back into the holster
your glock he pulls it out and he spins
it and shoots the knife
someone actually tweeted that i got like
700 retweets they were like he could
have just shot the knife out of her hand
do you know like do you know what guns
are like
do you know what a knife is like yeah
where she was the knife the victim was
in front of the knife
he would have shot the victim several
times to try and get the knife
dude this is like people really do think
it's the matrix
they do you can just like why don't they
just dodge the bullets why don't why
don't police just dodge bolts when they
get shot out
i genuinely don't think that anyone
actually watched the video because of
the commentary we're getting
absolutely insane they weren't looking
at the angle of the perp versus the
victim like there's a direct line
between the two there's no way around it
they don't care thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you